[Music]
hello and welcome back to the road to
2000 as always I'm Caleb Denby and I'm
gonna driver on this journey so today
the topic I wanted to talk about is
actually the isolated queen pawn the iqp
for short positions and it's a pretty
popular topic in chess and it comes up
quite often so are you guys familiar
with the IQ piece yet one yes one No
so basically it's it's just an isolated
pawn that's in front of the Queen so
it's the D pawn so we're gonna be
looking at positions from the slide with
the isolated pawn today and seeing what
some common plans are and trying to
delve a little bit deeper into the
specifics of it cuz you've probably
heard some rules already about it which
I'll get into a little bit later on but
yeah let's just take a look at this game
so this was a game that Dave Navarro
played against someone named hommerson
who I'm not too familiar with and poor
hommerson was out rated by about 500
points so it didn't go too well for him
but it was an instructive game to see
what kind of happens so it started with
Knight f3 d5 and the IQ P can actually
arise from a wide variety of openings
this is just one of them c4 and here we
saw a D take c4 so now we're kind of
gonna transpose into a Queens gambit
accepted kind of position so III Knight
f6 Bishop c4 so you can kind of imagine
how this would come from you know a
Queens gambit accepted kind of position
with III and Bishop takes there's just a
different way of getting to it different
move order kind of transposed we saw c5
so this is how we know we're gonna kind
of approach an i QP
Queen e2 C takes d4 so I want to ask you
what you guys might do here obviously
because the lecture is on isolated queen
pawns then guess what Dave Navarro did
but I want to see you know what your
first instinct would be how do you want
to take back on d4
with the night or with the pond first
instinct is the night and why is that
okay sure because you don't get the
isolated pun and so you know in chess
we're often taught that isolated pawns
are a weakness and you should avoid them
but you know the iqp can be a little bit
different because it sure it's isolated
it can become a target but very often it
can also be a benefit to the position so
what are some benefits to taking on d4
with the pawn to thinking like this so
yeah it opens up the e-file shirt that's
one important thing yeah just by virtue
of changing the structure it creates an
imbalance so you know there's going to
be something but I can play four and
something white can play four more
specifically the D pawn just on its own
does is quite a lot it controls a five
and a control c5 these can both be
pretty important squares and we're gonna
see this a v square come into play a
little bit later on it is actually a
really important square it's kind of
crucial to all of whites plans and I
keep you positions but maybe even most
of all most important of all it opens up
this bishop so now this Bishop has
squares a can go to it can kind of
contribute in any sort of attack and
we're not gonna have to worry about
being able to develop this guy whereas
if we were where to play Knight takes
the main I think downside is this
bishops gonna be stuck for a while and
sure we can play b3 and Bishop b2 but
that's going to take a little bit longer
and it's really not gonna be much of an
advantage for white or much of a try for
an advantage so I want to mention a
quote you might have heard the quote
before it's by tirage he said that he
who fears the isolated queen pawn should
give up chess so you guys got to start
taking on d4 otherwise trash is gonna be
mad at you so he takes d4 is what was
played in the game and it's what's kind
of recommended to try and keep the game
going we saw Bishop e7 castles
castles and now let's take a breath here
and try and think about what we want to
do with our pieces so let's look at the
white side we're trying to play from the
white side where do we want to put our
pieces let's just go one by one where
does this Knight want to go yeah c3
that's pretty simple right and then from
there it can look to maybe hop in later
to e4 to control d5 it has options on c3
on c3 even call it develops what about
this Bishop do we know where we want to
put it yet
sure f4 looks fine it eyes a lot of
squares on the Queen side but you know
like you said you're not so sure yet and
sometimes that's the right answer so
we're not entirely sure what the best
place for this bishop is so I would
leave it alone for a little bit and then
even more importantly than that where
does this rook want to go what do we
think yeah to the e-file would be kind
of interesting and it does go there and
quite a lot of lines there's actually a
better Square for it which is the only
other Square and yeah that's on d1
actually and the point might be a little
bit hidden right now but there is a very
specific point for putting the rook on
dd1 and it looks like a strange idea a
little bit later on in the game and
we'll try to find it but it comes up a
lot more often than you might expect
so Knight c3 Knight B to d7 so there are
a couple ways black can actually play
with Knight B to d7 or knight c6 and
both are actually probably okay here and
I'll talk about the difference a little
bit we wrecked a d1 and so we know what
we want to do right we put our rook here
we put our bishop here and we got our
night out and so let's talk about plans
for a moment you might have heard you
know a few principles about iqp
positions right so those principles
you've heard might be what does black
want to do more than anything let's
think about you know what our opponents
trying to do here
there yeah so not specifically moves I
mean
principles so you might have heard okay
if you're playing against the iqp you
want to do this and you want to do this
there are two big things that you might
have heard yeah that's the first big
thing is you want to blockade the pawn
you want to put a piece on the d5 square
to blockade the pawn whether it be a
knight which it usually is or anything
else so that's a big thing number one
and then what's important principle
number two for black well ok completing
development but that can be said about
pretty much any chess position is you
want to complete development what I'm
looking for is yes someone in the
youtube chata said it you want to
exchange minor pieces you want to take
off some pieces now why would that be
why would black wanna trade pieces so
yeah
the first thing is White's pieces are
more active the second thing is that
they're more active because this pawn
gives white a space advantage so when
you're when you have less space you
generally want to trade pieces and the
third thing has to do with what White's
plan is so you might have heard that
with you know with the iqp you need to
play actively right you need to play
actively and try to find some sort of
active advantage but so you might not
have heard that the way that usually
manifests the way that usually comes to
life in these positions is through an
attack on the king so to defend his king
black often wants to trade off some of
those minor pieces so he doesn't get
checkmated and then so black wants to
trade off pieces so that white doesn't
checkmate in if I can be as specific as
possible and
so yeah let's see how that manifests
here so we saw Knight b6 and the reason
for that is twofold when it threatens to
trade pieces which you know white
doesn't want to allow and two it's
preparing to put his knight on d5 where
he you know it's kind of the dream
square so white simply brings the bishop
back to b3 and I want to ask you about
that move so you given the choice
between b3 or d3 what choice would you
make and why and sometimes the bishop
does go to d3 so don't feel like you
know one of these is totally wrong so
that's one thing on d3 you're blocking
the rook but that's not the main reason
why a bishop III was played sure so yeah
on b3 you are still keeping your options
open to come back to c2 but I mean you
could do that through the d3 square as
well if you really need it to there's a
pretty important difference it has to do
with where we're going to end up putting
our other pieces later on
so yeah that's one thing that was
mentioned is on d3 the bishop does block
the rook this usually doesn't actually
become too important though because I
mean let's just say for example okay
I don't know turkey 8 and 95 this pawn
still isn't touchable yet because of
Bishop h7 so this isn't the most
important reason but let's take another
look at what you just mentioned so on e5
the knight does something pretty nice it
does a lot of nice things but one nice
thing is that pressures f7 and so this
is actually the reason why we want to
put the bishop on b3 instead of D 3 in
this case it's because you'll end up
seeing a crazy amount of tactics
actually that involved this Bishop
becoming very useful and pressuring
these two pawns let's say I don't know
Bishop d7 let's I don't know find some
move for white let's say Bishop g5 for
example so very often black will want to
play something like Bishop to c6 to get
it active and here already you know
white can kind of win the game so what's
the winning tactic here
yeah that's right night f7 and you know
of course this would be a little a
little bit too much I don't think the
king can get away with running to g6
though I haven't calculated it but so
yeah at night to f7 and so obviously
you're not expecting your opponent to
blunder this but it is kind of taking
away an extra option of bringing this
Bishop to c6 which can be quite
important yeah so I mean Turks see it is
a fine move but then you know White's
simply going to continue with the plan
and this Bishop isn't gonna be happy
you know the bishop would really love to
kind of get out of get onto this long
diagonal here but it wouldn't be able to
in this specific case so for that reason
which is mainly just to pressure these
pawns and whether it be for that reason
specifically or maybe other tactics
appearing later on the bishop goes to b3
a lot of the time so we did see Bishop
to d7 we saw this 95 move and so this is
really where the white knight belongs
and this opening is this e 5 square
that's where it can kind of do the most
Bishop c6 so now I want to ask you would
you capture this bishop obviously in
this case we don't have the same tactic
because this rook still on f8 i
protecting f7 so we could play Knight
takes c6 here though what do you think
about that move up side there down sides
place in the blacks hands how's that
yeah that's an excellent point one of
the most things one of the biggest
things black wants to do is trade off
some pieces and so that would trade one
set of pieces you know on the upside
though you might say well hey it's a
fairly open position and I have I have
two bishops compared to you know my
opponent's one
so maybe I'm bish my bishops can do some
work here but in addition to trading
pieces one other upside you might say
that well hey I have an isolated Queens
pawn but now my opponent has two
isolated pawns right so you might say
well he's got double the weaknesses I do
I have the bishop pair that should be
great for me but so what's wrong with
that thinking what's wrong
the first instinct is kind of right to
be a little wary of taking on c6
well sure it's White's turn but well no
I'm not saying black has a specific
threat I'm saying white probably
shouldn't go in for this just on for
positional reasons it's not going to be
a great forum sure so kind of expanding
on what you said you said the knight on
c3 is kind of blocked from moving moving
up now and the reason for that is this
pawn on c6 it's isolated but it's
actually a very very good pawn and the
first so the first reason that was bad
is it traded off a piece in an iqp
position the second reason is it
actually helps black blockade the pawn
even further it adds another defender to
d5 and then the flaw with thinking okay
well black has two isolated pawns two
weaknesses is it's really going to be
pretty tough to attack these guys c6
might be able to be attacked with the
rook on c1 someday but a seven really
isn't going to be too big of a weakness
in fact black might later push this pawn
down the board and kind of break up
White's pawns like that
so while Knight takes c6 is playable it
is actually kind of fine for white
because you know there are these certain
advantages it's not really in the theme
of an iqp position it's kind of really
changing the structure changing the
plans so in this game
white decided not to take on c6 I think
wisely and he played a pretty
interesting move I think so here I want
to stop and try to come up with a
winning plan for white give me given a
few moves what do we want to try to do
and this has to do with why we brought
this wreck to d1 rather than a1 so the
hidden point is gonna be revealed here
so let's give weight you know maybe a
couple free moves and see what we want
to do where we want to put sure so yeah
you're looking at some pretty crazy
stuff you want to break it open right
away whether it be through d5 which is a
upon sac or Knight takes f7 which
unfortunately I don't think either of
these can work right away
we'll see York takes and then I don't
know how you want to take back on e6
whether it be with the bishop or the
Queen
I think Bishop e8 and maybe black can
kind of hold on here and with d5 I I
don't think this works quite a quite
enough as well like thankfully has
enough defenders that you shouldn't be
in much danger here yeah and those
that's a great way to think about it
because these are pretty much two
critical moves where if black is played
incorrectly these are going to be the
moves that kind of win immediately for
white so you're doing well to think
about those but they don't quite work
here
so yet you're doing well again you want
to develop this bishop but once again
it's really not clear what the best
square is with Bishop g5 maybe black is
planning this move and again he wants to
trade off pieces at all if possible and
enough for it's a similar problem where
he might just run into getting attacked
right away so I mentioned earlier that
White's plan you know it's supposed to
play with activity and what does that
mean well it usually it means an attack
on the Kings side so we want to start
generating an attack on the Kings side
somehow how can we start shifting pieces
over to that side of the board
yeah Bishop c2 would be a fine move I
think but all right
yeah no this ideas I can't blame you
guys for not finding this idea because
it kind of shocked me at first too I
actually wasn't so familiar with these
positions until I started doing a little
work for tonight's class the idea was
rook to d3 and so work to d3 at first it
looks a little strange but the idea of
course he just wants to bring this rook
over to the Kings side and give
checkmate and so this is a very common
idea in iqp positions actually it's just
bringing this rook over to the Kings
side and just trying to deliver
checkmate using it and it's quite
powerful too it's kind of difficult to
stop so in the game we saw Knights B to
d5 and simply rook to g3 and now all of
a sudden they're very very very concrete
threats that look very dangerous for
black it kind of came out of nowhere
but this rook once it appears on g3 is
is quite a dangerous piece so in the
game black felt the need to play Knight
takes c3 B takes c3 and Bishop e4
so this was very very committal for
black right what is black done here
so the point of blacks play was he wants
to bring this bishop back to g6 Reagan
defend his king but what has he given up
on he's given up something pretty
important
what's the title of the lecture isolated
Queen ponds right this ponds not
isolated name anymore so black has
forfeited his main weakness in the
position so his main thing that he got
counterplay from was attacking this deep
on and now he's not really gonna have
that quite so easily anymore and so it
takes a lot for black to have to give up
on this pawn so what do you think's
wrong with something like King to H a
well actually White's activity is
already so great while it looks like
black has fully developed but none of
his pieces can really defend this King
quite well enough and so White's attack
is simply going to be breaking through
here actually rook h3 would be perhaps
the next move just keeping the stroke
opposite this King and aiming at some
more weaknesses then play might continue
something like you know rictus e8 a very
simple move getting develops but after
Bishop g5 now finally this Bishop comes
into action and now you know from the
different series it's not so easy to get
this piece to trade off right and it's
I'm pretty much the only defender of
blacks King this knight on f6 and so
black would have to try it to do
something about this
maybe h6 trying to give the knight this
h7 square but already it's it's far too
late after something like Bishop c2 an
IG 8 and Queenie for threatening a
checkmate
Knight back to f6 simply Queen to f4 and
black is just totally busted here
White's just going to take on h6 next
turn and pretty much win the game so
things can go wrong very very fast and
black kind of sense the danger so it
might be something that would happen
after King 2h it something like rook to
e8 would also be playable but once again
things are going to go downhill fast
after Bishop h6 and g6 black has made
quite a lot of weaknesses now this rook
no longer defends this pawn on f7 so
again you're gonna have these tactics of
Knight takes f7 popping up and after g6
the light score the dark scores are also
weak and you know this is also going to
be an idea
white so black didn't like the look of
these things which is why black ended up
giving up on the IQ P in taking and
going into what's called a hanging pawn
structure and now I think this is
actually gonna be quite good for white
so we see Bishop efore again the idea is
to bring this bishop back to help defend
and white already continues breaking
through with the move c4 after Bishop f5
we saw Bishop b2 simply defending this
pawn Knight up to e4 hitting that rook
simply rook e3 it's on Knight d6 and
it's pretty clear to see who's doing
better here
White's Knight is much more active again
it it can stay on e5 thanks to this D
pawn whereas black's knight has had to
move because of the absence of this
central pawn and wait in the game simply
continue breaking through in the center
after c5 and g4 already actually really
highlighting how blacks pieces have
simply run out of squares and after d5
it's pretty much over Bishop takes c5
takes and the tactics work out you can't
bring the King to the h-file because
this would be checkmate so you have to
give the exchange back my arrow key
stopped working strange
okay so rook up seven takes and this is
actually checkmate well close to it you
have to play 96 and blacks just totally
busted here his King kind of got ripped
open and so again that all happened very
very fast but it's all because you know
black had to give up kind of on this
Center to defend on the Kings side and
then white really managed to break
through almost immediately
uh yeah so here let's see there's it's
one of those positions where there just
has to be a tactic I'm not sure if it's
a Bishop b2
that looks pretty pretty good off the
top of my head I don't know where you
want to go with this Queen maybe just to
c5 and okay I mean there's there's stuff
like 97 here which is already kind of
crazy but you know obviously you can't
really take because of a because of this
kind of stuff and it's it's looking
pretty nasty it's looking pretty nasty
and okay I mean this Queen can go
somewhere else but there's still gonna
be it's not gonna be some some pretty
crazy ideas here so yeah I mean you got
to be pretty brave to take this pawn and
I'm sure the tactics work out for white
even if I'm not seeing all of them
perfectly here oh yeah any any questions
about this game though because I think
this is the main idea I want to stick
with you is first of all putting this
knight on e5 that's just where the piece
belongs secondly this idea of keeping
this Bishop to pressure on this diagonal
and then thirdly is bringing this rook
over this is a very very important idea
in the iqp positions any questions about
any of that
yeah well fair enough so if you're ever
a 2,200 playing it's the 2700 maybe
avoid the iqp because you're gonna get
checkmate that's the last moral of the
story let's take a look at maybe a
little bit more of a fair fight
we had a Sam Shanklin playing against
Valentin Dragunov girag now if I don't
know and let's see how we got there in
this case so d 4 + f6 c4 and it's
actually Queens gambit declines and this
is a pretty interesting pronged
structure here so have you guys seen
something like this happened in your
games ever yes once one yes one no so
the thing about this pawn structure is
it's almost guaranteed to end up in an
iqp position just because there's so
much tension in the center so many
players are gonna have to be you're
capturing that there's probably gonna be
a Nike
black held the tension for another move
and I do want to mention this is the
trash defense and trash is the man who
said he who fears the iqp should give up
chess so you know he likely had quite a
lot of experience himself with it having
this opening named after him
so quite finally breaks the tension with
pawn takes d5 and we saw Knight takes d5
of course white doesn't really want to
take here and allow black to develop as
bishop for free so he leaves the tension
there after Bishop d3 Bishop e7 castles
castles and white goes out and plays
this Queen e2 move
so this move that we've seen before and
this is really just a nice square for
the Queen in this opening the Queen can
go to c2 sometimes but e to is really
where it feels the most at home with
opportunities to come up to e4
opportunities to come out on this
diagonal different ways to kind of help
in the attack and actually on c2 in this
case of course that would run into some
specific problems so we see Queen e2
politics he takes a knight back to f6 in
this case actually so one difference
from the last game is black opted to put
this knight on c6 or other d7 so he's
putting a little extra pressure on this
deep on is pretty much all he's doing
here we see rip to d1 and now I want to
mention another very common maneuver
that shows up in iqp positions so if
black were to place something like rook
to e8 there's a very important move that
white can play here it doesn't win
material it's not a tactical move but
it's a positional idea that really would
improve White's position here see if you
guys can can find it
you
so you're thinking Knight to e4 the
problem is this doesn't make an
immediate threat really and the move
that I'm thinking about doesn't make a
threat threat either but yeah I don't
know 94 really you're just kind of
asking to trade pieces right and maybe
with the idea of removing an important
defender but 94 is interesting and does
show up a lot it's not really what I'm
thinking about here though yeah Knight
g5 is playable again you guys are trying
to make very very threatening moves it's
not the move I'm thinking of I'm
thinking of a very simple just
positional kind of kind of a
preventative move it prevents black from
doing something that black would really
like to do Bishop g5 b5 hitting the
knight so you are currently preventing
the move that I was worried about
preventing one problem might be is
you're kind of asking once again just to
trade off some pieces right you're
giving black these opportunities to
trade pieces so it might help if you see
what black played in the actual game so
once again one of blacks most important
ideas one is trading pieces and two is
blockading this pawn so in the game he
played night b4 rerouting this Knight to
d5 and the reason he did it immediately
is because if black were to waste some
time
play some random move like this now
white would play this move yeah simply
a3 and this would be a very very strong
move for white so in your games if you
ever do have the opportunity to play a
three it's a very strong idea against
this knight on c6 so it's not only c6
really the the best path for it is to go
from b4 and in to d5 and if it can't do
that then black is actually going to be
in quite a bit of trouble in some other
games you might see there's one other
way for this night to kind of get
involved and that's what the bishop come
to f6 and the other night coming to e7
but this maneuver has a lot of problems
a lot of problems with it one of which
being the move you guys were suggesting
maybe not immediately because it might
hang this
but there's these 94 ideas which will
always be hitting this Bishop and that
can end up being quite annoying and also
you know
Queenie for ideas as well now that
there's no knight on f6 can also put
blacks King in some danger so you know
black really needs to be playing night
before as soon as possible or you know
at least making sure you can do it
before white can get in 83 so yeah I did
want to mention that with this night
before idea of course white couldn't
play a3 in this turn because this pawn
would be would be hanging so that's why
we saw her rip D one night before right
away and simply Bishop c4 keeping that
Bishop and once again adding some
pressure on this long diagonal here we
saw b6 so once again black is finding a
way to develop in this case he gets the
long diagonal through b7 rather than
through d7 and c6 simply 95 again this
is really where that night belongs to
see Bishop b7 and simply a3 forcing this
knight to stop attacking quite so many
light squares here and forcing it back
onto this blockading position and now we
see once again Rick d3 so I wasn't lying
to you guys the site this idea of
bringing this rook up and over it's very
very common and it's very very important
and very useful for white this is what's
what wins a lot of games for white is
this rook lifts coming up and over and
then somehow someway breaking through on
the Kings side in this case though black
did manage to put up a little bit more
resistance so let's follow along here
played rook c8 again hitting this Bishop
white simply plays root 2 H 3 this time
he chose H 3 instead of G 3 honestly I
think rook g3 would have been fine as
well
but in this case white decided he would
rather kind of go after h7 rather than
g7 we saw Knight takes c3 so once again
we see the same idea of black feeling
the need to get this bishop into the
defense and this is an important idea to
remember for black 2 is when you're
really kind of under the gun like this
and you need that extra defender this is
a great way to try to get
back in the game as long as you realize
you know you're compromising your
structure well
you're fixing white structure not
compromising your own and so this is
kind of a last resort move for black you
don't really want to give white these
hanging pawns if you can help it unless
you know there's specifics in the
positions like you can blockade on c4
then it's probably good for you but in
general it's better to play against the
iqp without giving white these hanging
pawns the hanging pawn structure in the
game black did play Bishop II for the
same defensive idea and now actually is
where white came up with this g4 idea I
think someone in the YouTube chat
mentioned this one in some kind of
innocuous-looking position and in this
case it would be right so what is white
saying with with g4 what is white trying
to do yeah first of all there's a pretty
immediate threat of playing g5 and
taking this bishop so let's threat
number one what happens if black simply
just moves this bishop away
yes so I really think Knight takes
Bishop here would be would be quite
strong and you would have to take back
with the H pawn and I'm not sure if
there's immediate tactics it feels like
there might even just be some serious
sacrifices happening already but uh
likely you know why it's just gonna worm
his way over into a black scamp somehow
also something like g5 might come
followed by Queen g4 and you know Queen
h4 when the time is right and yeah this
would be pretty pretty bad for black
actually so we didn't see Bishop g6
actually we saw h6 so black again felt
compelled to move one of those those
Kings side pawns which in general you
might have heard this rule you don't
really want to touch your pawns on the
side where you're getting attacked
so again black is making more weaknesses
more compromises in order to kind of
save his pieces in the immediate moment
continuing on how do we think white
continued here let's see
what do we think white can do let's go
up with some some candidate moves to
keep this attack going
yeah Bishop takes h6 so you said it
might not be time yet and I think you
might be right here although it is
definitely one of the most important
ideas in the position is this sacrifice
on aged six so once again we see we
never really found a great square for
this Bishop but even on c1 it really
contributes to the attack just by adding
in these these extra threats so Bishop
takes h6 is a interesting idea
definitely I don't believe it is I'm
struggling to remember here
so I might be giving you guys kind of a
trick question see it see ya g5o another
interesting move let's see I wasn't
really sure how black was intending to
respond to this because it does look
quite dangerous yeah so takes Bishop
takes give me a Bishop f5 here and then
where do you want to go with the rook
then maybe Knight let's see I think I
can get away with 94 maybe I can't my
screen is flashing black that's
terrifying
okay 95 maybe yeah you're right on that
so probably not h7 is forced
well create five I can yeah so you
probably have to take here first and now
if Queen h5 I think I could play Queen
g5 was gonna be my idea so I played nine
h7 so if you play Corrine h5 I can just
take the bishop so I was thinking you
might take here first and then if queen
h5 I would have Queen g5 thankfully
check and hitting the queen and so black
could maybe start trading off some
pieces and so the point of this story is
yes these are important ideas these are
what you want to be calculating g5 and
Bishop takes h6 but this is one of the
hardest things in chess is when you're
attacking sometimes you just need to be
patient right and white simply played
Bishop d2 here he said my attacks not
going anywhere you're gonna have a tough
time bringing in any more pieces to help
defend and I'm simply gonna play Bishop
d2 I'm maybe going to bring in this
other work to help the attack and I'm
just gonna put my pieces on the best
squares possible and then and only then
will I break through with the sacrifice
on age six or this pawn push to g5 so we
saw Bishop h7 be played and now actually
wait again just call me plays Bishop to
d3 says this Bishop wasn't really
pulling its weight on c4 I'd much rather
trade it off for this defender on age 7
so that's what he did so Bishop d3 Queen
to d5 Black's aiming maybe to bring in
this Queen to help defend and now
actually we saw let's see what did we
see yeah rook to e1 so once again
White's very patient just brings in the
pieces absolutely no rush at all he's
controlling efore in this case
preventing black from putting a piece
there we saw Bishop takes Queen takes
Knight h7 and now the time is right so
black finally caved in he said wow okay
if I do nothing then g5 is simply going
to win right because now in this case
it's even stronger because we're
threatening made on h7 now that we've
gotten rid of that Bishop this is simply
just crushing
so black felt the need to play night h7
the idea of controlling this g5 square
so what do you want to do with white now
now's your time guys yeah let's go let's
go
Bishop takes age six and this is simply
winning finally it's simply winning and
but the important thing to remember we
saw those same ideas from the first game
the game the most site the main idea I
wanted to share in this game is the
patience the white head white really
didn't rush anything he waited until you
know he was certain the bishop tickets
age six was winning he got all of his
pieces involved he kept this knight on
the strong square and he you know first
traded off blacks key defender the
bishop on the light squares and then and
only then did Sam Shanklin break through
with Bishop takes age six and now this
is this is simply dead black did
recapture we saw rook takes back on h6
and black felt the need to play f5 to
try and save himself there's really no
better way to try to save this night if
you come to g5 maybe there's just pawn
aged for actually kicking this Knight
and you know mates kind of unstoppable
what about the square once again I think
something like just g5 hitting the
knight is really gonna be game over
so black felt they need to go in for f5
and it should be pretty clear that this
shouldn't be holding simply Queen h3
hitting this Knight once again black
tried to sacrifice on c3 white simply
ignores the rook and plays Queen h5 and
here is when black threw in the towel
and resigned so another stunning win for
the iqp do you guys want to play with it
yet are you ready to you know get that
iqp not be afraid because let me it
looks pretty good for white if things go
wrong it does look pretty good so any
questions about about that game about
how we got to this point
yeah fair enough once again I want to
say sure so I think in this case which
like I said I do think rich III would be
a fine move I think this would be fine
for white I think my white might
actually still have an advantage after a
g3 I just think in this case maybe white
thought black would play g6 and could
hold on a bit better in this position
than the last one
probably Bishop h6 would still come and
this would be you know quite dangerous
still for black but you know black might
drop this Bishop back and I think white
just decided he'd rather go in for this
rook h3 where he didn't see a very clear
defense rather than this forcing this
kind of weakness for it for the long
term
I do think both moves would be good
though I do think both moves would be
good other than that again main thing to
remember with the defending side with
the black side here this night before to
d5 maneuver is the most important
maneuver I think when you put this
knight on c6 and so if white ever has
the opportunity why should be playing a
three in this game black didn't give
white the chance cuz black was a very
strong player but that's an important
maneuver to remember and then the second
thing I want to stress is the patience
of this attack right
you know white launches the attack with
g4 but after h6 white doesn't panic
doesn't try to play g5 right away when
he saw that the lines weren't working
out for him he simply plays Bishop to d2
trades off that defender and gets his
last jerk in the game and then and only
then is it enough for white to really
break through and win okay with that in
mind we've got some time left let's take
a look at the third game I want to go
over so this is maybe the highest-rated
game of the night
that's between gelfand and Korchnoi so
two giants in the chess world yeah let's
just take a look at how we got there
so we saw d4 d5 C for ticks
another kind of qga type position see
five castles 96 queenie - once again
this e 2 square becoming a very common
place for the queen to go
we saw c takes d4 or if d1 and white
once again captures back with this pawn
and it's especially clear here knight
takes is really almost never never
correct for white you know here White's
giving up very little in fact he's even
opening the file with their opposite the
Queen but Calvin still chooses to go for
this i QP it's really not something to
be afraid of it's almost it's almost an
advantage for white I would say getting
these iqp type positions we saw a
castles a3 so like I said in this case
black castles getting his King out of
the center and white said no I'm not
going to actually let your knight come
to b4 I'm gonna play a3 while I still
have the chance and so we'll see now
maybe this other maneuver that black can
try to get this knight to blockade so we
see Knight d5 and Knight c3 in response
black plays rook e8 white simply drops
this Bishop back to a2
maybe he was worried about some Knight
a5 stuff and just simply tucking this
Bishop away is totally fine for white
and now black did something pretty
interesting and pretty committal so yes
it's possible that black could play
normally still with something like
Bishop to f6 I think would be pretty
normal
putting pressure on this pawn but once
again it's something like 95 might come
and already I think black should should
probably take here because something
like Knight to e7 really isn't going to
cut it after something like Knight to e4
and you know these are the type of moves
that I said you really have to be
worried about when this knight on c6 and
doesn't find its home on d5 is something
like 94 coming and really you know
pressure on the King side kind of really
amps up quickly when you can't get that
night where it belongs
and so looking at stuff like this Court
should we actually decided to go in for
an interesting line here so of course
took on a three which actually does not
hang a bishop despite what you may think
so of course what is what is the point
what happens if we we take care yeah
Knight c3 hitting e 2 and E 1 a little
bit trickier
what happens after Bishop takes d5
threatening ok 3 loner Vaughn Raymond
good to see you in the chat oh no not
Bishop takes B to white would simply
recapture and be up a piece
so yeah before is available but you know
it's it's a little more urgent than than
you the positional stuff here cuz you
know whites trying to win a piece he
takes this knight on d5 maybe with the
bishop and so if black just recaptures
we want to play rook a3 but actually
this was the point of rook e8 from from
Korchnoi is he can actually recapture
here winning a tempo on the Queen so we
don't quite have time to take this
bishop so because of that the tactics
actually work out for black and we saw
Knight takes d5 once again black has to
take with the pawn putting pressure on
this Queen so now we saw Queen b5 and
after I'm sorry Bishop d6 the point of
whites play is also revealed he lost
this pawn on a3 but he's getting it back
on d5 and so this was kind of a crazy
way to get into what's still in iqp and
so the plans are obviously going to be a
little bit different here because it's a
wildly different position than the last
ones we looked at but yeah this is the
position now so just to quickly recap
how we got there
black probably didn't really like his
position after a3 happened so he found
this interesting way to change change of
the structure he took on a3 allowing a
the specific line where it's still an
iqp but it's a different type of iqp and
you know ii 6 + a3 have kind of been
traded for each other and this strange
tactical line so what do we thinks going
on here what do we thinks going on here
would you rather be black or white
rather be white why is that so yeah
there's a few things like you said
there's the space advantage and like you
said white has a lot of threats going on
right away so because you know his
pieces were more active so black really
has to try and consolidate if he wants
to be okay here so let me put up a
random position though let's say
something like I don't know something
like h6 happens white cashes in and
takes this pawn we see Bishop e6 maybe
even a different square but let's say e6
and I I don't know maybe d5 and Bishop
g4 or something and you get a position
like this who would you rather be now
would you rather still be white or maybe
things are turning around
that's why a dark square bishop
sure so all of a sudden it looks like
black might have some more activity but
you know white does have a central pawn
for it so I'm really not sure who's
better here but the point being if black
can get his pieces out if I can
consolidate kind of without giving up
too much whites certainly not just going
to be kind of crushing this game right
yeah there's there's there's certainly a
lot of problems going on especially with
this night so because of that we
actually did CH 6 what do you think
would happen if we just developed this
Bishop here right away
okay well first of all actually I just
hung b7 but let's say I make a better
move
I don't know Queen c7 what actually has
a pretty annoying move here
yeah so this is idea that what this is
the idea the black was worried about in
the game is 95 really put some
uncomfortable pressure on the 7f 7
square so that's why I black committed
this extra turn with h6 just to stop an
IG 5 of course though you know white has
another square available and that's a 5
so white went ahead and jumped on to e5
rather than trying to go in for this you
know captures on the c6 line so yeah 95
putting pressure on f7 and once again
black felt compelled to make a capture
so we saw Bishop takes on e5 and pawn
takes on e5 and now the tactics actually
work out that black can't quite
recapture this pawn thanks to some
Bishop f7 stuff not right away I think
you have to maybe kick around this rook
first before Bishop f7 but the point is
okay black can't take back on e5 just
yet and so once again white has used his
activity to force black to kind of
capture something and change the
structure so what do we think about this
change of structure you know this pawn
moving from d4 to e5 who does it benefit
so yeah activity wise you know it's it's
helping white out a little bit
activating this rook but overall is the
pawn better on d4 or 'if I've not even
just in the mediate in the immediate I
mean going forward as well yeah that's
that's exactly right rather than being
stuck with an isolated pawn now this
pawn is actually where it you know can
have some support after move like f4
which we wouldn't see in a position like
this but eventually in an endgame you're
actually going to find out that's you're
going to find out by what was played
that's this pawn on e5 is actually quite
a quite a nice pawn and the last thing
it it does grab even more space it's
even more ambitious and taking space
than the pawn on d4 was so we still
Queen to c7 here now he is threatening
to take this pawn so we did see Bishop
f4 just defending it Bishop to e6 and
now Wyatt says okay Bishop f3 I want to
keep the bishop pair and more moves were
played I don't want to spend too much
time on this because it's really not too
complicated of a position both sides are
just bringing their pieces to the center
and White has kind of already solidified
his advantage in that he has the strong
e5 pawn and it's not going anywhere
this is where White's advantage is
coming from in addition to having the
two bishops so we saw Queen e7 Bishop b3
who should be three and now Wyatt again
has no reason to fear endgames anymore
because he no longer has an isolated
pawn he has a strong e5 pawn so we saw
it takes Bishop d3 hitting the bishop
bishop comes back to a4 Bishop g4 so
again white eventually is going to
defend this pawn he's just kicking
around blacks pieces first rook to d8
rook to d6 is actually again indirectly
defending this pawn through tactical
means if the rook were to take here
where it actually has a nice tactic rook
C takes
see six and white would be winning a
piece thanks to this jerk on d8 so okay
you can't capture this pawn yet ripped
to a eight and now finally f4 so again
now we see this pawn is no longer
isolated and white simply plays f4 to
defend it so we saw an egg d8 Rick to
see it takes takes and we got closer to
this end game here and after takes takes
takes takes we're finally in a an
eventual end game and so this is where
white managed to win this thanks to some
maneuvering thanks to having this strong
Bishop against the not so strong night
and having all this extra space in the
center and I'll go through it and show
you how the game ended but the scope of
this class was supposed to be mostly
about the IQ P so any questions about
how we got there because the kind of the
advantages that Whitehead kind of
shifted throughout the game and but it
was all thanks to his activity he used
his activity to force black to take on
e5 which gave him the structural
advantage and the advantage of having
the bishops against the bishop in the
night which turned into a straight
Bishop versus Knight endgame so any
questions about that
in particular no all right so yeah let's
see what happens
King f2 white simply brings his pieces
into the endgame following all the good
principles bringing the King up and in
and this point on e6 really ended up
telling the tale here
so after you know advancing his pawn up
he brings his king over and we can see
he wins this pawn in h5 and it's a story
of the bishop being a long-range piece
and the knight being a short-range piece
the bishop pressures the Queen side and
helps aid and cleaning the pond the
knight can only do one so he has to give
up on the Queen side to come saved on
the on the Kings side here and here is
actually where black resigned he played
King d5 hanging the night for some
reason before he resigned but I mean a
move like this wouldn't really change
the evaluation white was simply winning
either way simply pushing this point
forward boy it's the wrong bishop but he
isn't up to Brook pawn here's the knight
pawn so let's say something like this
happens do you have to be a little bit
careful here I think I might actually
have to play Bishop d8 here
you can't take because I would queen
king c4 Bishop here King b3 and now I
get to protect my pawn forever and you
can never really threaten it with your
upon which I'm not entirely certain okay
well I guess the big problem is once the
King leaves I can take this Knight is
okay so either way you know eventually I
put this Bishop on a3 and that will that
will win the game no matter where my
king is so yeah that's how that I'm game
ended up once again the main points to
remember are these specific maneuvers
and where the pieces go
that Knight comes to e5 in almost every
game this rook lifts with rook to d3 and
over to the Kings side is very very
important don't want to forget about
those maneuvers for black with the
knight on c6 coming to b4 and the idea
for white of a3 to prevent that and
hopefully you know this class gave you a
little bit of an idea of the common
tacking plans for white and how white
can really kind of break through using
this isolated queen pawn with that in
mind that's all for tonight thank you
guys for joining me thank you guys for
watching on youtube and join me next
week next Wednesday
you
[Music]